bonjour ici Catherine merci bonjour ici
Gérald philian c'est avec grand plaisir
qu'on vous présente une émission
spéciale dans le cadre du Jour de la
Terre qui a lieu à chaque année le 22
avril cette année le thème c'est
investir dans notre planète on va se
demander est-ce que l'économie est
l'environnement c'est vraiment contre
nature oui est-ce que protéger
l'environnement sa nuit forcément à
l'économie est-ce que ça nuit à la
croissance de l'économie on va tenter en
tout cas de déboulonner le mythe qui
oppose toujours l'environnement et
l'économie on va en discuter avec trois
experts qui s'intéressent de près à cet
enjeu fondamental pour l'avenir de
l'humanité et on va tenter de répondre à
plusieurs de vos questions c'est parti
[Musique]
le Canada se réjouit à l'idée de jouer
un rôle et tracer la voix la plus
efficace pour l'avenir
gouvernement fédéral a qu'une entente
pour acheter le pipeline nous allons
continuer d'avoir besoin de pétrole
on a besoin de ça pour travailler
[Musique]
on n'a pas vu ça millions d'animaux par
an au Canada on pourrait sauter une
journée de temps en temps et vraiment de
manger moins de viande mais de la
choisir mieux c'est juste un changement
d'habitude on voit pas un animal on voit
un morceau de viande
on consomme beaucoup trop si tout le
monde continue à prendre l'avion pour
ses vacances ça va être compliqué
qu'on prenne le vélo ou l'auto il y a
aucun incitatif
ça va être de plus en plus des véhicules
électriques qui vont rouler dans le
troisième lien avec les données qu'on a
ça ne justifie pas l'implantation d'un
tunnel routier
mais sans être dogmatique en 2050 nous
on veut que nos enfants aient encore une
planète Terre de l'eau potable et puis
des ressources pour manger aussi
alors nous nous trouvons sur le site du
jardin botanique à Montréal à la maison
de l'arbre Frédéric Bach
avec nous François Delorme économiste
consultant et chargée de cours au
département d'économique de l'École de
gestion de l'Université de Sherbrooke
vous avez collaboré au Groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat le GIEC et vous êtes également
chercheur au laboratoire des inégalités
mondiales
environnement et professeur associé à
l'Institut national de la recherche
scientifique vous vous intéressez à
l'adaptation au changement climatique et
aux pratiques agricoles durables à
l'économie circulaire aux pesticides aux
insectes vous êtes aussi cofondatrice de
tricycle qui produit des insectes
comestibles et des engrais organiques et
Maxime penoujobin ancien maire de la
Ville de Gatineau et collaborateur à la
presse alors bonjour à vous trois merci
de participer à cette émission spéciale
je vous pose la question justement avec
François environnement économie est-ce
que c'est un opposition François est-ce
que c'est contre nature
longtemps été je pense que de plus en
plus ça ne l'est plus
maintenant on est capable d'intégrer des
questions économiques à l'environnement
et
d'incorporer la nature dans nos
décisions économiques donc c'est un faux
débat on devrait plus avoir aujourd'hui
excellent Louise j'irai même plus loin
que ça si on protège pas notre
environnement on va détruire notre
économie tout simplement Maxime
avec des inondations des tornades puis
ça coûte cher il faut s'occuper de
l'environnement quand on parle de lutte
contre les changements climatiques c'est
important quand même de ne pas laisser
reposer toute la pression sur les
épaules des citoyens mais est-ce qu'il
faut se déresponsabiliser pour autant
est-ce que les petits gestes comptent
les estimations varient mais le Canadien
moyen émet entre 15 et 20 tonnes de gaz
à effet de serre par année en combinant
toutes les sources or le GIEC est très
clair pour limiter le réchauffement
climatique à 1,5 degrés plus chacun doit
réduire son empreinte carbone à
seulement 2 tonnes d'ici 2050 bien sûr
les industriels et les gouvernements
devraient être tenus de faire leur part
à côté de ça éteindre les lumières et se
mettre à la marche est-ce que ça fait
vraiment une différence bien apparemment
oui en France la firme carbone 4 évalue
qu’un français exemplaire qui prend
moins l'avion qui délaisse l'auto solo
qui devient végétarien et qui achète des
biens durables d'occasion peu
éventuellement réduire son empreinte
jusqu'à 25%
et si il ajoute à ces petits gestes des
investissements pour isoler son logement
ou remplacer son véhicule et bien notre
cousin héroïque peut même en théorie
voir l'économie atteindre 40%
. c'est vrai personne n'est parfait et
nous n'avons pas le même mix énergétique
que les Français mais quand on regarde
la facture GES réduire de 320 g de
viande rouge par semaine c'est de
réduire d'une tonne ces émissions de gaz
à effet de serre 10 000 km de moins en
RAV4 2019 à essence c'est une réduction
de 1,86 tonnes 1000 dollars de moins en
vêtements est souliers 9
0,5 tonnes de moins et un vol
aller-retour Montréal la vanne en classe
économique de moins c'est une réduction
de 0,8 t
la conclusion semble évidente oui les
petits gestes comptent
d'emblée vous y croyez vous à
l'importance des petits gestes pour
faire une différence par rapport aux
grandes décisions collectives Louise je
pense que c'est important pour tout le
monde de se responsabiliser puis il
devrait dans la limite de son domaine du
possible donc chacun devrait poser des
petits gestes chacun doit être
sensibilisé y croire voir c'est où qu'il
doit faire les meilleures options mais
maintenant est-ce que les petits gestes
vont remplacer les grandes démarches
structurées que les gouvernements
peuvent nous aider à atteindre que les
grandes entreprises doivent déployer
bien entendu non il faut pas que les
simples citoyens est toute la
responsabilité sur ses épaules de
changer nos pratiques environnementales
en ce moment parce qu'on va décourager
les gens chacun a sa part de
responsabilité et le citoyen lui-même
peut prendre des bonnes décisions je
pense la première décision qu'on doit
avoir c'est de réduire notre
surconsommation déjà ça va faire une
différence
on se demande vraiment les petits gestes
si c'est pas une pression sur les
individus Maxime mais moi toute
franchise
aux gestes on faisait des phases dans le
bureau en disant on scanne sur tout du
papier glacé ou du papier peau glacé il
y a une bouteille d'eau ou un verre
d'eau au Conseil télé alors que on fait
de l'étalement urbains on investit pas à
sans transport en commun moi j'ai
souvent trouvé que c'était des façons
notamment pour des élus de d'avoir l'air
environnementaliste alors que dans le
fond ça change pas grand chose pas en
soit tous les petits gestes comme on dit
sont importants mais quand tu es un élu
ton travail c'est pas de te vanter que
toi tu restes mieux que les autres c'est
assuré que le recyclage se fasse une
bonne façon à la ville qu'on compost
puis que la corporation que
l'organisation municipale livre la
marchandise
cette impression que ça sert pas à grand
chose les petits gestes il y a beaucoup
de gens qui pensaient quand même
François mais je pense que les petits
gestes sont nécessaires mais ils ne sont
pas suffisants et
c'est les gestes par qui quand on
regarde un peu comment est-ce que les
gens émettent par niveau de revenus les
40% les plus pauvres et mettent 10
tonnes par année par personne puis au
Canada en 2021 le 1% les plus riches ils
émettent 190 tonnes par personne par
année donc c'est pas seulement les
petits gestes mais c'est qui commence à
faire les gestes qui sont conséquents
mais justement qu'est-ce qui fonctionne
le mieux la carotte ou le bâton
si je peux me permettre en économie
comportementale quand on mélange la
psychologie avec l'économie on voit que
malheureusement c'est le bâton qui
fonctionne les incitatifs sont
importants mais les études
expérimentales montrent que la taxe est
taxe et plus efficace qu'une subvention
pour générer un changement de compte
donc le marathon c'est la taxe c'est
d'aller mettre une taxe à un prix pour
que les gens paient ce prix ou le
contournent en changeant de comportement
parce qu'en mettant une taxe on perd
quelque chose en même temps quand on
regarde toute la communication sur les
changements climatiques juste les verbes
se résigner à ne plus prendre l'avion
diminué ou renoncer à la vie à des
sacrifices pour l'environnement est-ce
qu'on communique la bonne façon moi je
pense qu'on a des grandes erreurs de
communication le mouvement
environnemental pendant longtemps
pensait que simplement en donnant des
statistiques sur les changements
climatiques s'en viennent chiffrer la
pollution chiffré la perte de
biodiversité ça allait capacité
spontanément les gens à prendre de
bonnes décisions or c'est pas le cas ça
peut même au contraire décourager
générer de l'anxiété donc dans la
communication ce qu'il faut penser à
faire c'est on dit en anglais where the
beach elle est où la plage où on veut
aller se projeter dans un futur qui est
plus simple qui est une aire plus pure
que de l'eau propre dans laquelle on
peut se baigner qu'il y a des aliments
qui sont sains qu'on se balade sur la
rue qu'on entend les oiseaux gazouillés
moi personnellement c'est là que j'ai
envie d'être donc ce sera pas des
sacrifices pour m'y rendre ça va être
des actes régénératifs reconstruire
l'environnement autour de nous c'est
certain que les gens se rendent pas
toujours content de ce qui est en train
d'arriver on le voit pas nécessairement
vous vous le voyez en même temps quand
vous étiez mère de Gatineau il y a eu
des inondations il y a eu des tornades
est-ce que ça aide à éveiller les
consciences des gens ça quand ils
arrivent des catastrophes le verglor
récemment aussi dans le sud du Québec
peut peut-être aussi avoir réveillé
certaines consciences
je peux politiser mais je vois quand
même répondre oui mais non vous répondez
comme un policier encore parce que oui
c'est sûr que ça conscientise si moi je
trouve qu'on parle on pourrait parler
plus de souffrance humaine qui vient
avec des catastrophes comme ça là moi je
j'ai beaucoup de gens qui ont beaucoup
souffert et perdre leur maison on
perdent toutes sortes de cesser c'est
vraiment de la vraie souffrance ça faut
en parler parce qu'il y a une source
puis c'est la source c'est climat les
dérèglements mais
les inondations 2017 on se passe au
printemps c'est l'année électorale
donc on se met en mode électoral à
l'automne on vote en octobre au dernier
conseil ou l'avant dernier conseil
tout le Conseil sauf mon équipe on voter
pour construire un concessionnaire en
zone inondable ça c'est à peu près à 200
mètres de l'endroit où il y avait à peu
près 30% de toutes les sinistrés du
Québec dans point de Gatineau un
quartier pauvre même une rue là où il y
avait je me rappelle et une famille il y
avait trois maisons de la même famille
ils ont tout perdu leur voisinage leur
maison leur historiques familiales leur
communauté mais ça c'était quoi 5 mois
après la catastrophe parce que il
voulait non c'est parce qu'il voulait
nous dépenses la politique participe
contre ceux qui étaient contre le
développement puis qui croyait pas dans
le développement économique on t'a des
méchants donc c'est un espèce de vote
selon moi absurde 5 mois après une
catastrophe terrible encore ému quand je
parle de ça parce qu'il y a eu du monde
qui ont souffert à 200 mètres de cette
affaire-là mais j'aimerais seulement
préciser quelque chose que Louise disait
sur le requal la recalibration le
changement du discours un fumeur là si
tu lui dis ben faut que j'arrête de
fumer c'est sûr il est en manque il voit
le coup du manque de ça mais il faut
être capable de se projeter comme Louise
le disait et tu vas être en meilleure
santé tu vas vivre en meilleure santé
probablement plus longtemps et c'est
là-dessus ou le discours écologiste le
discours des champions climatiques doit
porter à moins le sacrifice c'est vrai
qu'un sacrifice moi je ne lis pas là il
y a ce qu'on parle de décroissance par
exemple il y a toujours une privation ou
la suffisance de mais il faut changer ce
vers projetons-nous vers qu'est-ce que
ça va nous donner de faire ce coup-là à
court terme pour des gains qui sont à
long terme j'ajouterai tout à fait
d'accord que il faut expliquer ce que ça
donne aux gens puis il y a un discours
un peu fleur bleue mais il y a aussi un
discours très concret nous on est la
première grande ville je crois avoir
tarifié les sacs de vidange qui
dépensent le 120 litres que tu as le
droit de mettre dans ton après 120
litres on tarif 50 sous c'est pas grand
chose il faut que tu achètes un chat un
sac
on a fait beaucoup de choses mais dont
celle-là on a rendu nos écocentre
gratuits Gatineau après je pensais deux
ans on était la grande ville qui
produisait par habitant le moins de
déchets vitesse 100 kg par habitant de
moins par année que le deuxième c'est
pas rien ben là on se vante le pendu aux
gens Gatineau vous êtes bon là on est on
assume du leadership puis ça a pas été
si dur il y a plein de cas particulier
difficile qu'il faut gérer mais
globalement le 120 litres si on se
recycle puis on compost c'est jouable
faut l'expliquer aux gens il faut se
vanter de nos bons coups il faut dire
qu'est-ce que la ville a économisée
est-ce qu'on devrait généraliser ce
principe du pollueur payeur Louise mais
on le voit déjà il y a des
responsabilités élargies des producteurs
qui sont développés dans différents
domaines on parlait de la récupération
pour fin de recyclage mais le Québec est
en train de faire une véritable
révolution de la façon dont on finance
la récupération pour fin de recyclage
maintenant les entreprises vont être
responsables jusqu'à les matières soit
réintégrées dans de nouveaux produits
donc il s'agit plus qu'on parle
responsabilité à partir du moment où
l'entreprise met l'objet en marché elle
va devoir récupérer la matière et la
réinsérer à l'intérieur de nouveau
produit c'est de l'économie circulaire
c'est de l'économie circulaire et on
cherche à faire ça le plus possible
localement sur le territoire donc éviter
d'exporter des matières recyclables dans
des grands conteneurs jusqu'à dans des
pays asiatiques puis créer des incidents
diplomatiques avec ça on est capable de
le faire sur notre territoire on
comprend donc que les petits gestes oui
ça compte mais est-ce que le gros du
travail il est pas ailleurs dans des
grandes décisions structurantes qui sont
bien au-delà des citoyens
moi j'en suis convaincu il faut que les
gouvernements fassent leur travail faut
que les entreprises les grandes
entreprises fassent leur part puis je
dirais que ça c'est plus facile de poser
un petit geste comme citoyens sont
simples nos gouvernements prennent des
décisions courageuses si il est ça
allait mon petit effort à moi qu'est-ce
qui vaut vraiment je pense quand même
légitime l'autre merci restez là bougez
pas dans un instant on va se demander
s'il faut aller plus loin encore dans
nos changements d'habitude faut-il
arrêter de prendre l'avion dans un
instant Montréal Paris c'est 1,75 tonnes
de CO2 vol aller-retour alors qu'il
faudrait assez rapidement diminuer à
deux tonnes par année nos émissions de
CO2 on voit que ça fonctionne pas c'est
tout un défi
[Musique]
Gérald Catherine l'industrie de
l'aviation ça représente 3% des
émissions mondiales de CO2 est-ce que ça
veut dire qu'on devrait sentir coupable
de prendre l'avion mais peut-être qu'on
devrait sentir coupable mais en même
temps je pense à toutes ces familles qui
doivent voyager à l'étranger pour voir
leur famille puis oublie pas non plus
que de voyager ailleurs dans le monde de
voir d'autres pays d'autres villes
d'autres cultures ça ouvre l'esprit
certains en même temps moi il y a une
statistique qui m'a un peu ébranlée
quand je l'ai apprise dernièrement quand
on regarde la population mondiale il y a
que deux à quatre pour cent des gens qui
ont déjà voyagé à l'international donc
il y a une question aussi de justice un
peu là-dedans non
on pourrait dire peu de gens polluent
beaucoup
les gens sont privilégiés ceux qui
peuvent prendre l'avion sont assez
privilégiés 21 millions de vols de
passagers sur des vols réguliers au
Canada c'était l'été dernier on est
revenu en fait au Canada au même niveau
qu'avant la pandémie c'est beaucoup de
carbone on est privilégié mais on aimait
beaucoup de carbone et quand on regarde
aussi qu'un vol par exemple Montréal
Paris c'est
un 15 tonnes de CO2 un vol aller-retour
alors qu'il faudrait assez rapidement
diminuer à deux tonnes par année nos
émissions de CO2 on voit que ça
fonctionne pas
on nous dit qu'on peut compenser nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
cliquant ici puis on va planter des
armes l'industrie va investir à peu près
1500 milliards d'ici 2550 pour se
décarboner on peut se demander si c'est
juste pour nous donner bonne conscience
n'est-ce pas en attendant compte tenu de
l'empreinte que ça tout ça peut-être que
l'idéal c'est de voyager moins voyager
mieux peut-être
je suis curieuse vous logez vous sur
cette question est-ce qu'il faut arrêter
de prendre l'avion repenser le voyage
diminuer je pense qu'il faut réduire
drastiquement au minimum à l'essentiel
mais si on est pour se déplacer sur de
très grandes distances pour rationaliser
aussi les déplacements c'est mieux
d'être en classe Économie d'un avion
pour un très long voyage que d'être deux
dans une voiture et se rendre jusqu'au
bout de l'Amérique du Sud en terme
d'émission de gaz à effet de serre en
même temps on le mentionnait des fois de
s'ouvrir vers le monde plus je parle pas
de la mondialisation de l'économie puis
de délocaliser nos emplois puis notre
production qu'on exporte partout ça fait
pas beaucoup de sens mais en même temps
de s'ouvrir sur le monde par le voyage
c'est d'apprendre à aller vers l'autre
le découvrir ça nous permet de découvrir
des nouvelles cultures des nouvelles
façons de faire de s'inspirer de ramener
cette inspiration là chez nous de
découvrir aussi la nature ailleurs ce
qui nous porte à vouloir protéger pas
seulement le monde qu'on connaît dans
l'immédiat mais la planète entière donc
il y a quand même des vertus
à voyager si on était capable si on
avait le loisir de le faire comme gratin
[Rires]
que ça je pense que comme Louise le dit
il faut restreindre le plus possible
puis ça nous ramène un peu à
une question philosophique qu'est-ce qui
est nécessaire puis qu'est-ce qui
superflu qu'est-ce qui est un besoin
dans le fond exactement puis bon je sais
pas peut-être pour quelqu'un de voyager
et tout ce que vous avez mentionné c'est
toutes des bonnes raisons mais à un
moment donné ok mais là il y a une
restriction on a une cible de diminution
de GES on a le GIEC nous dit il nous
reste 7 ans pour changer de direction
mais si je dis oui mais encore un autre
voyage en avion puis c'est mon dernier
puis là j'envoie mes enfants un moment
donné il faut prendre des décisions qui
sont cohérentes moi j'insiste beaucoup
sur la cohérence est-ce que je connais
vraiment la culture de la côte nord ah
peut-être pas puis peut-être que c'est
ça qu'il faut que je découvre avant de
m'en aller au Sumatra
urgence climatique si on vend juste au
climat ça va vers l'avion mais si on
reconnaît que une urgence mais il faut
de façon urgente changer nos
comportements et ça peut être l'avion
qu'on change ça peut être d'autres
choses mais ce qui est comportements
changent pas on est cuit le climat
changeant le dérèglement s'arrangerait
pas ce qu'on va jusqu'à rendre nos clés
de notre véhicule utilitaire sport puis
je pose cette question là puis on la
pose de temps en temps parce que
différentes études qui sont publiées là
dessus il y a toujours une montée de
boucliers de la part du public on le
sent la zone économie notamment les gens
veulent pas laisser tomber leur vie US
affirmant souvent que c'est possible
émetteur que ça moi je rêve du jour où
j'aurais plus besoin de m'occuper d'une
voiture de la stationner de l'entretenir
si je pouvais m'en départir demain matin
je serai la personne la plus heureuse au
monde je suis presque rendu là mais
j'habite entre deux villes et c'est pas
évident parce que je prends presque
toujours le train
euh ou l'autobus mais sérieusement quand
ça prend à 4h30 5h faire Québec Montréal
en train c'est pas viable donnez-nous
des TGV s'il vous plaît donnez-nous des
moyens qu'on ait envie de se déplacer en
transport en commun j'aime beaucoup
mieux être sur le train faire tous mes
appels toutes mes vidéos conférence avec
une connectivité Internet qui fait du
sens
travailler pendant tout ce temps-là
plutôt que d'être pris dans le trafic
sur la route d'arrivée stressée à
destination
il faut avoir des options
ça a pas de sens de prendre une voiture
pour s'en aller en Gaspésie quand on
pourrait avoir un train qui s'y rend
avec toutes toutes les commodités qu'on
peut avoir puis l'électrification des
transports dans tout ça ça règle quoi
quelle partie du problème
moi je dirais que c'est une petite
partie je dois donner un exemple qui moi
ma profondément troublé parce que c'est
un ami qui me dit
le gouvernement va investir 5 milliards
pour électrifier les autobus au Québec
c'est de l'argent ça 5 milliards c'est
formidable électrifié
5 milliards on améliore le système
autobus au pétrole puis on enlève des
autos de la route là le gain
environnemental est beaucoup plus grand
enfin il faut évaluer aussi ce qu'on
gagne puisqu'on perd et puis souvent
l'électrification oui mais si son change
pas le modèle urbain si on continue de
s'étaler si les gens sont stationnés
dans une auto électrique sont quand même
stationnés tout seul dans une auto c'est
une autoroute qui est à peu près jamais
utilisée puis qui nous coûte cher
faut pas que ça nous empêche de changer
de modèle de développement si ça fait ça
on n'a pas avancé le gain qu'on a en
électrifiant les voitures par exemple et
c'est par moins de pollution
atmosphérique localement je veux pas
dire qu'on n'aura pas d'émission net
parce qu'il faut la construire cette
voiture là les batteries sont lourdes
c'est complexes il faut extraordinaire
il faut des mines ça demande de plus en
plus de minéraux critiques et
stratégiques construire des technologies
neuves donc on peut pas penser que c'est
magique faire ça par contre dans une
phase de transition si on se dit pas on
remplace toutes les voitures thermiques
par des voitures électriques puis on
continue à rouler sur l'eau dans nos
voitures ça fait aucun sens en
continuant à faire l'étalement urbain
mais dans un centre-ville s'il y avait
pas de voiture thermique et seulement
quelques véhicules électriques on
pourrait améliorer la qualité de l'air
en attendant on nous dit qu'on a encore
besoin de pétrole et c'est le ministre
fédéral de l'environnement qu'il
l'affirme cette semaine dans son rapport
sommet
30 millions de barils de pétrole par
jour en 2050 dans un monde carbone
neutre donc ça va diminuer énormément on
va passer
de 100 par jour vous savez je n'ai
jamais eu de voiture je n'en aurais
probablement jamais mais quand je prends
le train pour venir à Ottawa ce train-là
fonctionne au pétrole je pars du
principe que dans la mesure où nous
allons continuer en tant que société en
consommer pendant le week-end aussi bien
consommer le pétrole que le moins
d'impact sur l'environnement et qui en
plus devraient carbone neutre François
Delorme vous êtes d'accord avec ce que
vous venez d'entendre
non je ne suis pas d'accord avec ça je
pense que quand on essaie de demander
aux gens d'être cohérents on demande aux
gens de changer
il faut aussi que les institutions se
lèvent et se mettent à hauteur des défis
qu'on demande aux gens donc c'est
important que les gouvernements les
institutions donnent des bons signaux on
n'achète pas un pipeline on donne pas le
feu vert à Baie du Nord c'est c'est là
on n'est pas dans les petits pas dont on
parlait au début là on est des grands
pas en arrière donc ça juste pas de sens
là au Canada le Canada s'appuie sur les
ressources le gaz et le pétrole rapporte
tellement dans les finances publiques
pour payer les services publics comment
on peut dire qu'on décroît sur le gaz et
le pétrole au Canada Maxime mais je me
demande si on a le choix de pas le faire
on le fait pas chaud là en tout cas mais
si on le fait pas puis la température
continue d'augmenter c'est des
déplacements de population tu sais c'est
les scénarios catastrophes de films on
s'en va vers ça fait que si on décide
pas que les sables diminuent restent
dans le sol
c'est ça les grosses sources la menace
elle est pétrolière puis le Canada agit
comme un nez mais est un état pétrolier
puis si on assume pas ça puisqu'on
décide pas de changer ça c'est là où je
reviens l'idée que c'est dur de demander
aux gens de fermer lumière puis de
composter quand on voit qui achète un
pipeline avec notre argenté c'est un
moment donné c'est une incohérence
spectaculaire oui
on ne peut plus tolérer aucun nouveau
développement pétrolier ou gazier dans
le monde si on veut respecter nos
engagements climatiques c'est assez
clair et il faut arrêter de penser
uniquement au gaz à effet de serre
l'environnement là c'est plein de
facettes quand on extrait des sables
bitumineux ont pollu des étendues d'eau
gigantesques on sait même pas comment
les épurer ont eu plein d'animaux
migrateurs qui vont dans ces morts
toxiques là et qui en mer on a des
produits
aromatiques politiques qui s'en vont
dans l'atmosphère qui viennent dans
polluer les gens des Premières nations
ça va dans lait maternel ça a occasion
des cancers on dégrade beaucoup d'autres
facettes de notre environnement dont
notre source la plus précieuse au Canada
c'est l'eau
fort intéressant après la pause on va se
demander si les technologies peuvent
nous tirer d'affaires c'est toutes des
flèches qu'on devrait avoir dans notre
carquois étirer sur la même cible qui
est le 1.5
[Musique]
alors la question fondamentale François
est-ce que la technologie peut sauver la
planète la technologie ne s'ouvre pas
elle est un élément essentiel comme
depuis le début on parle de plein de
choses les petits gestes les
institutions tout ça ça fait c'est
toutes des flèches qu'on devrait avoir
dans notre carquois et tiré sur la même
cible qui est le 1.5
mais,5 degrés Celsius d'ici 2100 en
termes de réchauffement climatique ça
c'est notre cible le danger c'est de
nous déresponsabiliser de dire s'il y a
une main salvatrice qui va venir régler
le problème sans que moi je m'inflige un
certain inconfort sans que je réduise
mon nom de mon nombre de voyages en
avion par exemple pourquoi est-ce que je
le ferais maintenant j'ai juste à
attendre Louise vous vouliez réagir ah
mais vraiment parce que je suis tout à
fait d'accord là avec le fait de dire la
première chose qu'il faut faire c'est
réduire à la source le problème les
technologies vont pas tout solutionner
par contre il y a aussi un autre risque
de dire les techn partager les
innovations technologiques c'est mal on
devrait pas investir dans la recherche
scientifique menant au développement de
nouvelles technologies parce que on tire
à côté de la plaque il faut réduire il
faut tout chambouler notre système notre
société faut continuer à développer les
technologies respectueuses du climat on
peut continuer à développer des
technologies aussi qui s'inspirent la
nature il y en a de plus en plus des
technologies où on va utiliser les
services écologiques rendus par la
nature pour nous livrer des services
dans nos sociétés humaines on parle de
phytotechnologie par exemple qui mis sur
les plantes qui vont nous permettre
d'avoir des bâtiments qu'on a moins
besoin de climatiser avec des toitures
ou des murs végétalisés on va parler
aussi de biotechnologies qui utilisent
des micro-organismes qui vont nous aider
à mieux recycler de façon plus optimale
nos matières organiques tout en général
de l'énergie on va parler des
antotechnologies avec des insectes pour
nous permettre de recycler nos matières
résiduelles et produire des aliments
donc les solutions technologiques elles
sont là on doit continuer à les
développer mais elle ne doivent pas être
la pierre angulaire de front là de tout
ce qui va nous sauver parce que c'est
pas le cas
j'ai un peu sceptique et je donne un
exemple qui j'espère est approprié mais
quand on parlait de la société des
loisirs on va être plus efficace on va
avoir des ordinateurs on va voir si donc
on va voir du temps pour se reposer avec
la famille on a juste travaillé plus
c'est que si on produit plus avec des
technologies plus propres mais qu'on
produit plus pas sûr qu'on va voir aidé
quoi que ce soit si on continue à
consommer pour moi la technologie est un
outil il se passe pas un résultat on l'a
vu beaucoup dans le domaine de
l'aviation ça notamment les avions
aujourd'hui sont beaucoup plus efficaces
que dans les années 60-70 mais tout le
gain en efficacité énergétique et annulé
parce qu'on il y a beaucoup plus
d'avions dans le ciel c'est ça c'est
comme à l'école
se récompenser
mais en économie on aperçoit de faire
bon c'est de ça dont on parle la
technologie baisse les coûts de
production c'est on est plus efficace
mais finalement on baisse le prix de
vente aussi et les gens en achètent plus
donc finalement la technologie en effet
pervers peut avoir un effet pervers et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut faire attention
chose certaine une industrie comme celle
du pétrole et du gaz et l'énergie
fossile puis on a parlé un peu plus tôt
dans l'émission parce que c'est
tellement important dans l'économie eux
disent le captage du carbone voilà la
bonne solution qui de mieux que
l'industrie pour capturer le carbone de
séquestrer et le stocker sous terre
c'est un produit que l'industrie connaît
par coeur et c'est une industrie qui a
les moyens de le faire actuellement et
qui se fait dire constamment par les
marchés et paroisse ensuite qu'il faut
accélérer la transition la conférence
qui a eu lieu en Alberta a été un
tournant pour l'industrie en fin de
semaine c'est là qu'on a vu les acteurs
majeurs de l'industrie se positionner
très fermement dans la capsule et le
retrait de ses émissions là de
l'atmosphère et je suis convaincu que
c'est la façon la plus rapide et la plus
efficace de baisser drastiquement nos
émissions alors la technologie du
captage de carbone
évaluer par l'industrie pétrolière vous
en pensez quoi d'abord François ben en
ce moment il y a pas un modèle
économique qui nous permet d'avoir la
captation la séquestration de carbone à
grande échelle à un prix qui permet aux
entreprises d'être rentable donc c'est
pas moi qui l'affirme c'est une gilbaud
le ministre de l'Environnement qui le
dit à votre micro Géral et c'est sûr que
quand on entend ça comme une solution
magique moi ma question comme économie
c'est à quel prix moi je pense que on ne
devrait jamais associer les technologies
de capture séquestration du carbone à
une continuité des opérations
d'extraction des combustibles fossiles
la terre c'est un non sens par contre
c'est vrai qu'en ce moment c'est eux qui
ont les capitaux et qui développent
beaucoup ces technologies là
séquestration la captation est le
séquestration du carbone géologique peut
se faire effet du sens parce qu'on prend
du CO2 dans l'atmosphère et on peut le
transformer en roche littéralement qui
apprendre plus jamais dans l'atmosphère
on doit continuer à développer cette
technologie là mais pas comme pour
pallier à contenant et mettre n'importe
quoi mais est-ce qu'il en existe une
technologie qui pourrait nous aider et
qui serait bonne économiquement et qui
pourrait nous aider à limiter notre
impact
c'est comme un leurre aussi les
nouvelles pourquoi on se car les
vipineaux qui disait pourquoi on
développe pas les anciennes technologies
les trains c'était anciennes
technologies changer de régime
alimentaire c'est une ancienne
technologie il y a moyen de de au lieu
de toujours être je dirais médusé par
des nouvelles choses essayons
d'améliorer ce qu'on a en ce moment et
voyons quel est le potentiel de faire ça
avec ce qu'on a en ce moment donc moi je
pense qu'il y a un danger le Carthage de
carbone c'est un peu ça c'est oh oui ça
va régler mais en ce moment là ça
fonctionne seulement pour certains cas
particulier à des coûts qui sont très
élevés donc moi j'y crois pas je pense
qu'on vraiment regarder ce qu'on a puis
optimiser ce qu'on a pour commencer mais
simplement mentionner que la
carbonatation minérale c'est un
processus géologique naturel qui existe
depuis des siècles bien longtemps avant
d'autres nouvelles technologies que vous
avez évoquées mais qu'il faut quand même
aussi continuer à s'inspirer de ce qui
se passe dans le monde géologique dans
la science de la terre dans la nature et
d'optimiser ce qu'on voit ce qui se
passe dans les processus naturel autour
de nous pour les accélérer ou les outils
pour nous livrer un service écologique
en particulier il y a une super vieille
technologie sur la planète que je trouve
très intéressante en matière
d'aménagement urbain ça s'appelle le
village
parce que cette façon-là d'aménager la
la vie humaine c'est là où tu habites tu
travailles tu consommes dans des loisirs
à même place dans ton village ça peut
être un village urbain ça peut être un
quartier d'une grande ville il faut
aussi revenir à des technologies comme
ça qui font qu'on émet beaucoup moins de
GES que chaque citoyen d'un village
conçu comme ça voilà au sein de ton
village j'aimerais implanter une autre
encore plus vieille ce sont des arbres
si on pouvait simplement planter des
arbres dans nos villes on aurait notre
technique de captation du CO2
atmosphérique ça projetterait de l'ombre
sur nos maisons ça épuré l'air en bien
ça capterait l'eau pluie pour éviter le
ruissellement donc il y a plein de
technologie qu'on peut juxtaposer comme
ça le gouvernement fédéral vient
d'annoncer 83 milliards sur dix ans pour
attirer des investissements dans les
technologies propres pendant ce temps-là
Québec mise sur l'électrification vous
en pensez quoi mais je pense que c'est
une excellente chose là c'est quand on
parle des petits pas c'est un moyen pas
dans les bonnes directions Louise en
parlait tout à l'heure il faut
encourager les technologies font partie
de du package dont on a besoin pour
avancer et je pense que c'est excellent
on a souvent souligné aussi lors du de
l'annonce ce programme là que on faisait
du rattrapage par rapport aux États-Unis
mais quand on met ça en proportion du
PIB l'effort canadien c'est de 3%, celui
des États-Unis c'est un point 6% donc le
400 versus le 80 on voit que
proportionnellement parlant le
gouvernement canadien en fait plus que
les Américains à ce niveau-là et mise
beaucoup plus sur les technologies
finalement les technologies propres pour
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre les technologies c'est une chose
mais la gouvernance également c'est très
important le Canada se classe au 55e
rang sur 60 États dans le dernier
palmarès de l'organisme Germain watch
sur la performance en matière de lutte
contre les changements climatiques il y
a vraiment beaucoup de pays qui font
beaucoup mieux que le Canada
faut être ambitieux mais sans être
dogmatique ce sont les mots du Premier
ministre le goût lors de son discours
d'ouverture en novembre dernier mais
quels sont juste nos ambitions nous nous
sommes fixés l'objectif audacieux
d'atteindre la carbone neutralité d'ici
2050 pour être capable d'atteindre on
l'espère d'être parmi les premiers la
capo neutralité en 2050 pour atteindre
cet objectif il vrai que nos émissions
se mettent à diminuer de manière
significative très rapidement ce qui
n'est pas le cas mais est-ce que de
grandes économies enregistrent des
baisses marqués de leurs émissions la
réponse c'est oui l'Allemagne et la
France sont deux bons exemples en plus
elles ont réussi ce qu'on appelle un
découplage depuis 1990 leur pays B a
augmenté alors que leurs émissions elles
ont diminué en allemand elles ont même
chuté de 40%.
oui
le pays industrialisé qui a réussi à
décarboner son économie le plus
rapidement c'est le Royaume-Uni les
émissions de GES britanniques ont
diminué de près de 50% depuis 1990 alors
qu'est-ce que les Britanniques ont fait
ils ont opéré entre autres une grande
refonte du secteur de l'énergie
désormais la majeure partie de
l'électricité provient de sources
renouvelables derrière le succès du
Royaume-Uni il y a aussi un consensus
politique sur la question ce qu'on n'a
pas au Canada et le pays a été le
premier à introduire un budget carbone
dans ses lois ce budget diminue au fil
des années pour mener jusqu'à la carbone
neutralité en 2050 l'autre pièce
maîtresse du succès britannique c'est la
gouvernance les politiques du
gouvernement les grands projets
d'infrastructures par exemple sont
analysés par un comité indépendant pour
voir s'il corresponde à la trajectoire
de réduction des GES ce qui ne veut pas
dire que les Britanniques sont tirés
d'affaires pour autant parce que
jusqu'ici les réductions n'ont pas eu
d'impact sur le confort et le mode de
vie des gens c'est l'avenir où il sera
question de l'isolation des maisons de
l'alimentation des transports risque
d'être beaucoup plus complexe à mettre
en œuvre
qu'est-ce qui vous inspire dans ça parce
qu'on a l'impression que ça prend
beaucoup de volonté politique de
faisabilité politique alors que les
échéances électorales reviennent
rapidement qu'est-ce qui vous inspire
dans ce que vous venez d'entendre mais
je sais pas si je lis bien mais moi ce
que j'ai vu c'est que c'est un élan
collectif c'est incapable d'aller
chercher un consensus moi je suis pas
sûr qu'elle à l'échelle canadiennes on
serait capable mais certainement l'échec
québécois de dire on s'assoit tout le
monde ensemble mais je me rappelle une
certaine époque on a fait le déficit
zéro avec l'accord des syndicats il y
avait mis d'autres choses en balance ça
avait été complexe mais il y avait eu un
certain consensus pour des décisions
difficiles moi je trouve ça intéressant
de l'essayer puis justement on sortirait
de l'économie ou l'environnement on
serait capable d'avoir une vision
commune puis je pense avancer par sa
presse dans 7 ans si c'est pas un grand
élan collectif on l'atteint pas là
François ben il faut des politiser tout
ça puis je pense que comme on le fait
pour la question maximire en parler sur
le défi de zéro il faut avoir des des
organismes comme le directeur
parlementaire du budget sur les finances
publiques à Ottawa et et l'organisme
indépendant au Royaume-Uni permet de
garder comme un chien de garde
ce que vous avez mis c'est pas réaliste
ou retournez travailler et on va on va
valider ça à chaque étape la gouvernance
et la clé là-dedans c'est un élément
important dans le carquois encore c'est
une bonne flèche il faut se mettre des
garde-fous pour les retours en arrière
on l'a vu qu'en Trump est arrivé au
pouvoir il voulait balayer du regard
revoir la main l'accord de Paris
le cleaner Act aux États-Unis aussi les
législations sur différents pesticides
on voulait toutes régresser aller en
arrière au Canada on le vu encore
récemment avec la clause poil lièvre
pour éviter de revenir en arrière sur
les décisions qui ont été prises de
mettre un prix sur le carbone donc on
doit absolument sécuriser tous les gains
qu'on fait en matière d'environnement
que ce soit protection de la
biodiversité du climat ou de la
pollution environnementale ce sont les
trois grandes menaces qui pèsent sur
l'humanité et on ne devrait en aucun
temps toléré des politiques publiques
qui puissent revenir en arrière
simplement selon le où on va avec le
courant politique d'actualité après la
pause je dirais la question qui tue
n'est-ce pas faut-il arrêter de manger
de la viande
en Amérique on consomme beaucoup trop de
viande beaucoup trop de viande
industrielles lorsque même un boucher
nous dit de manger moins de viande il
n'y a peut-être quelque chose là
[Musique]
manger ou pas de la viande ou en manger
moins quand il est question de ce qu'on
met dans notre assiette ça peut
rapidement devenir confrontant mais
quelques faits sont éclairants d'abord
la production de viande à l'échelle
mondiale et responsable de 14,5% des
émissions de la planète c'est le bœuf et
le lait qui arrive en tête des aliments
carnés avec l'empreinte la plus lourde
c'est pas tellement surprenant parce que
ces aliments la viande de bœuf le
fromage le lait proviennent de ruminants
dans leur processus de digestion naturel
ces animaux-là et mettent beaucoup de
méthane impuissant gaz à effet de serre
autre enjeu l'élevage accapare
énormément d'espace sur la planète on
estime que les trois quarts des terres
agricoles du monde servent à l'élevage
ce sont soit des pâturages ou des champs
de culture qui nourrissent les bêtes
évidemment tous les animaux n'ont pas la
même empreinte celle du boeuf pèse
particulièrement lourd parce qu'il faut
10 kg de grains pour produire un kilo de
viande donc la conversion n'est pas très
efficace beaucoup destiné aux animaux
des céréales par exemple pourrait
nourrir directement les humains par
contre c'est l'industrialisation des
méthodes d'élevage qu'il faut souvent
problème certaines études ont démontré
que le bœuf il vit non pas dans des
parcs d'engraissement mais dans des
systèmes de pâturages rotatif permet de
stocker plus de carbone dans le sol en
Amérique on consomme beaucoup trop de
viande beaucoup trop de viande
industrielles et ça ça le si on rajoute
la couche d'impact sur l'environnement
de cette production là on gagne tous à
manger moins de viande notre slogan
c'est vraiment de manger moins de viande
mais de la choisir mieux lorsque même un
boucher nous dit de manger moins de
viande il y a peut-être quelque chose là
en fait ce qui est clair c'est qu'au
Canada on mange trop de viande c'est
mauvais pour notre santé et ça fait
gonfler notre empreinte carbone et notre
facture de soins de santé alors après à
nous de choisir
alors ma parole Louise ce qu'il faut
tous devenir végétarien je crois qu'on
doit tous faire un examen qu'on
conscience et réduire le plus possible
notre consommation de viande si on
pouvait substituer plusieurs repas de
viande dans la semaine ou simplement
utiliser mieux la viande donc dans
plusieurs pays du monde on utilise la
viande pour parfumer les plats au lieu
d'être un plat central dans notre
assiette ça serait mieux pour
l'environnement ça serait mieux pour
notre santé ceci étant dit la viande
animale elle-même elle est pas toute née
égale c'est sûr que la viande rouge ou
si on mange les agneaux ou les veaux
quand elles sont encore jeune et tendres
leur empreinte carbone est bien plus
importante mais si on va un peu plus bas
en terme de grosseur d'animaux qu'on
mange du poulet mais son empreinte
carbone est vraiment nettement moins de
poulet c'est beaucoup mieux le poulet
que le bœuf effectivement on pourrait
aller encore même plus bas si on mange
des escargots si on mange des insectes
ce sont des animaux qui nous donnent des
protéines complètes qui ont une
empreinte carbone beaucoup moins une
recette parce que ils sont à sang froid
donc il gaspect moins d'énergie et
manger à se chauffer donc on peut manger
plus bas dans la pyramide de la semaine
alimentaire François ben moi je suis
d'accord je pense qu'on doit substituer
si on tient absolument à manger de la
viande pour des raisons qui m'échappent
d'accord parce que c'est bon oui par
exemple peut-être parce qu'on fait ça
depuis longtemps
mais je pense qu'on doit substituer
comme Louise le dit à des choses qui
sont moins émettrice de GES mais on doit
tendre vers une alimentation qui est de
moins en moins Carné et c'est ce que le
Gillette nous dit dans son chapitre 5 de
2 avril 2022 Maxime vous êtes omnivore
vous êtes chasseur vous mangez de la
viande comment vous voyez je trouve que
le chevreuil a une empreinte écologique
à peu près nul donc c'était intéressant
la viande sauvage je trouve une belle
transition parce que moi je peux tout à
fait prêt à devenir carnivore mais à
devenir végétarien mais les chiffres
sont assez clair s s'il y a pas de les
données probantes sont très probantes il
faut diminuer la consommation mais
effectivement la viande c'est ça que le
pire impact par contre si on consomme
des aliments qui sont locaux non c'est
ça exactement si on consomme des
aliments qui sont tropicaux et qu'on
doit importer en camion réfrigéré et
qu'on a des forts taux de pertes aussi
de gaspillage le pendant le transport un
fruit qui se meurtrit il sera pas vendu
donc je pense que si on se tourne vers
une alimentation locale qui est
respectueuse on va avoir un animal qui
est en pâturage par exemple au lieu
d'avoir un animal qui ne mange que de la
moulée composée de maïs cette soya sur
laquelle on a appliqué des pesticides je
pense qu'il y a moyen de réduire
l'empreinte de notre alimentation en
ayant une consommation plus respectueuse
est-ce que d'autres aliments qu'on
devrait bannir de notre diète moi je
pense qu'il faut faire c'est se
détourner le plus possible des
monoculture industrielles intensives que
ce soit de la viande ou que ce soit des
céréales c'est l'huile de palme ou le
café qui est produit en éradiquant des
forêts ça ne fait aucun sens non plus
donc ce qu'il faut réfléchir c'est d'où
provient mon aliment à ce qu'il est
traçable est-ce que je peux connaître le
producteur est-ce que je lui donne le
juste prix pour qu'il puisse vivre
dignement aussi mon fermier de famille
donc si on se tourne vers des choix
comme ça et qu'on est plus consciencieux
aussi à limiter le gaspillage des
aliments dans notre réfrigérateur et
d'essayer de chercher moins la
perfection dans les aliments qui sont à
l'épicerie comme ça les épiciers vont
aussi moins gaspiller d'aliments je
pense que c'est comme ça qu'on va
réussir à changer le monde faut pas
chercher un changement drastique du jour
au lendemain mais si le consommateur les
commerçants et les producteurs mettent
la main à la pâte pour changer les
choses on peut y arriver est-ce qu'il y
a un politicien qui va être capable de
convaincre les Canadiens de moins manger
de viande Maxime
mais je pense que c'est un effort
collectif il faut qu'on soit conscient
de ce que je pense moi je crois pas dans
les sauveurs je crois pas que une
personne peut faire mais je crois dans
le consensus collectif je crois dans le
dans le dialogue dans les échanges je
crois dans des outils c'est pas tout à
fait sur la question mais moi je le
trouve intéressant on a un marché de
solidarité en Ottawan le marché de
l'outaway ou les petits producteurs
peuvent moi je peux sur internet me
faire ma commande d'épicerie c'est
toutes des producteurs locaux c'est du
poisson c'est de la viande c'est des
légumes c'est des épices c'est
extraordinaire je fais une consommation
qui est beaucoup moins lourde en termes
de GS parce que c'est toutes des petites
producteurs locaux qu'on aide mais ça
prend plein de mesures comme ça c'est ce
que François disait le sapin énormément
de mesures puis consommer moins de
viande moi je pense que les chiffres tu
es une erreur qu'on fait souvent
politique c'est qu'on prend les gens
pour des imbéciles puis ils le sont pas
si on leur explique puis si on fait de
la pédagogie puis ça je pense que il y a
une part de puissions paye on leur fait
payer le vrai coup aussi c'est la
carotte mais le bâton là moi je pense
les gens peuvent changer merci beaucoup
à vous trois d'avoir pris le temps
Maxime baie de nosjobin louisiano éty
François Delorme ça a été un plaisir
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]
Gérald on s'est demandé si le mariage
économie et environnement était
forcément malheureux contre nature moi
j'ai l'impression à la suite de nos
discussions Catherine ce que j'en
comprends en tout cas c'est qu'il faut
réduire notre consommation fossile ce
qui va avoir un impact négatif à court
terme sur l'économie certainement mais
il faut investir dans ce qui décarbonne
l'économie ça ça peut avoir un impact
économique à court terme qui est positif
si on fait tout ça mais peut-être qu'à
long terme on aura des effets positifs
sur l'économie mais surtout sur
l'environnement est-ce qu'on sait aussi
c'est que le coût de l'inaction il est
beaucoup plus élevé et plus on tarde à
agir plus ça va coûter cher et plus les
conséquences sur l'humanité seront
grande exactement donc on ne peut pas et
on ne peut plus opposer l'économie et
l'environnement moi ce que je retiens
aussi c'est que polluer l'environnement
dégradé l'environnement ça a un coût on
peut plus l'ignorer maintenant
exactement bon alors on espère à la
maison que vous avez apprécié cette
émission et que c'est venu susciter
quelques réflexions chez vous et
peut-être même des débats qui vont se
poursuivre à la maison qui sait alors
merci de votre attention qu'est-ce qu'on
mange ce soir écoute je te laisse
décider et cuisiner d'ailleurs bonne
chance merci et à la prochaine merci
[Musique]